and experience suggests collaboration is
often the necessary to deliver complex
platforms I'm optimistic that the UK
industry will benefit from such
collaboration
stupid okay
very grateful to the uh Secretary of
State for the answer Mr Speaker he'll be
aware that when the former prime
minister made his statement on the Orca
steel bike on the 15th of September 21
he was absolutely emphatic the the deal
was going to lead to hundreds of Highly
skilled jobs in Scotland the north of
England and the Midlands when does the
Secretary of State think these jobs will
be created and can he give me any idea
about the specific locations yeah
we also said at the time that there
would be an 18-month study program where
we work out both design and indeed
workshare for this submarine that is
drawing to a close and we are waiting
obviously for the Australian government
as a whole to make its decision uh on
what August looks like I think given the
amounts of money that Australia will be
spending on this Enterprise the need for
international collaboration and the fact
that in Barren furnace and fast lane we
have one of the very centers of
excellence globally that will help
deliver it I'm confident that all those
statements will turn out to be exactly
as they were made and just to give some
indication we are increasing the number
of jobs in Barrel already from 10 000 to
000 people in order to fulfill both the
Dreadnought program the nuclear
deterrent and the next generation of
Britain's attack submarines Simon Phil
thank you Mr Speaker may I thank my
writable friend for the considerable
effort that his Department the
government and the Navy have put in to
securing this important agreement it was
heartening at the commissioning of HMS
Anson to see representatives from the
Royal Australian Navy and also the
Australian government present and also
the announcement that Australian
submariners will be training on that
vessel too with that in mind would my
writable friend agree with me that this
agreement is absolutely crucial to
securing a new geopolitical and
strategic agreement with Australia the
US and the UK on issue on areas such as
subsea and cyber to keep us safe
I'm grateful to my friend and look Baron
Furness devonport and fast lane are key
components for delivering our nuclear
submarine capability and can almost not
be replicated around the world and it's
very very important we recognize
especially in skills look when Australia
chose to go for nuclear submarines as an
option it did so because it recognized
about five countries on Earth can do
this and it is important if it wants to
retain a strategic Edge in the Pacific
in its part of the world against any
future adversaries we know that that's
what we did for the last 70 years uh in
the Atlantic alongside our American
friends Australia I'm delighted on
joining that program how to Docker to
use Mr Speaker the orchestra was
supposed to be the defining agreement of
the indo-pacific Tilt that this
government said in the integrated review
I'm sure the Secretary of State remember
was to make the UK European partner with
the broadest and most integrated
presence in the indo-pacific now given
today's news and a combination of
historic defense cuts and inflation are
going to make the high hopes of the
integrated review harder to fill this
time I wonder can the Secretary of
statement perform the house whether it
will still be the UK's aim to be the
European partner with the broadest and
most integrated presence in the
indo-pacific
but it it's right to ask those questions
it is still our ambition and you know so
far two of the planks already in place
all kids and we'll see the full details
and it is no mean undertaking to commit
uh to helping build another country
build that capability and be engaged in
its training and deployment that is a
very deep and enduring the United States
investment and joining with us all those
decades has lasted for 70 years in that
that is a tilt by any means uh basis but
also we've had carrier strike group on
its visit only two years ago that's
continued and we planned for another one
in 2025. thank you Mr Speaker more
broadly Mr Speaker what steps is my
right honorable friends Department
taking to further strengthen and broaden
the alcus alliance
the second pillar of orcas includes
things such as Ai hypersonics and cyber
and all sorts of other technologies that
are critically vital not only to
complement deployment of Submarine but
also to further engage our collective
security and those are technologies that
rarely are shared between nations but
the united states recognizes that that
in order to face up to the end of this
decade and the challenges that we make
sure we share together both our
Industries and their industries that we
have protection for all of us from each
other's markets to make sure that we we
share and then get to sell into them as
well which is quite important so
Secretary of State John Beverly
this week like the Secretary of State
I'll be meeting the Australian defense
minister And discussing orcas with him I
want him to know that there may be a
change of UK government at the next
Elation but there will be no change in
Britain's commitment to office if done
well this pact could deepen our closest
alliances it could strengthen Security
in the indo-pacific and it could bring
game-changing investment to Britain so
what priority has the defense secretary
given to building the first Subs here
and when will the build plan be
announced
I I'm welcome to the right honorable
gentleman's uh support for all kiss and
uh I noted point on a government there'd
be no obviously no complacency from the
labor party opposite Mr Speaker uh I
hope they wouldn't repeat that what
happened once in the 1990s I I think the
reality is uh you know it makes good
security sense the labor front bench
recognize this labor front bench
recognizes good Global Security even
though the last one didn't uh the the
questions that my right on my friend uh
so I'm a gentleman asked I have to say
of matter for the Australians they will
make the decisions ultimately they are
ultimately the customer in the sense of
where they're going to spend the
Australian taxpayers money we of course
have contributed to the discussion and
offer and Australia will have to make a
decision about time how quick it wants
his capability uh it will have to make a
decision about how much it wants to
build in Australia and it will have to
make decisions about what's the right
fit for its ambition Britain or the
United States is existing Fleet I
suspect that will come sometime in March
if not in February I'm very happy to
keep that right honorable gentleman up
to date but we have put in a good
proposition and our relationships and
I'm delighted he is meeting his campaign
Mata number three Mr Speaker
the Minister of Defense as the UK's
biggest landowner is delighted to
welcome a range of people to use the
land including Walkers mountain bikers
Riders and as long as they use the land
responsibility
uh welcome on the land no one however
should receive special treatment
thank you Mr Speaker there was a
memorandum of understanding that
facilitated the monitoring of Trail
hunting on his Department was out now
sadly Trail hunting is sometimes used as
a smoke screen for illegal hunting and
the defense infrastructure organization
has recorded incidents of foxes killed
on Ministry of Defense Lang and the
threatening conduct of Sam Hunt staff so
could the secretary say tell us whether
he was aware of the serious concerns in
the Dio over the behavior of hunts
licensed in his name and what Vice was
given by officials
first of all I'm glad the honorable
members raised the mou the mou was put
in place without any announcement to
Parliament any informing of members of
this house without even putting it in
the library as normally would be for a
change of policy by any government now
that was obviously disturbing to then
discover this policy existed and gave
special treatment to one group of users
now I'm sure he doesn't want people to
have special treatment I think everyone
has a right to use that land that way it
also coincided with a large donation to
the labor party at the turn of the
century from a whole group of those
animal right people it's corrupt Mr
Speaker that's what that is corrupt a
policy unannounced to this house after a
funding donation to one political party
and now they're asking for special
treatment everyone everyone should
respect each other on how they use that
land what I am aware of having now
investigated even further is there are
plenty of complaints from other sides
and this is not about size this is about
whether one group gets special treatment
none
I understand the case I don't expect the
government well in that case I don't
expect the mod will be taking any credit
for the work that the conflict stability
and Security fund does the reality is
that over the years the government has
made a habit of double counting spending
to both uh the Oda Target and the NATO
two percent defense Target and of course
the home office is busy reading the OD
budget at every chance it gets doesn't
that do a disservice to what both the m
the m the NATO two percent Target and
the ode Target are supposed to achieve
Mr Speaker I think the connection to the
NATO Target is somewhat tenuous but
there is a pattern to The Honorable
gentleman's questions I think this is
the fourth time he's asked this question
in orals as well as a number of written
questions I think his point is
principally aimed at foreign office
colleagues and the treasury
um but if he would like to meet with Mod
officials um to discuss once and for all
the mod's plans for the use of this Voda
I'd be very happy to facilitate such a
meeting chair of the slight committee
Tobias Elwood thank you Mr Speaker
speaking of budgets and Ukraine could I
invite the minister to respond to
comments from the United States our
closest security Ally which tally with
the defense commit his own findings that
this conflict in Ukraine has exposed
serious shortfalls in the war finding
capability of the British army this is
not about the professionalism of
individuals units or formations but
about the overall combat strength and
the equipment they use as well as the
ability to meet increasing demands
caused by the deteriorating threat
picture
Mr Speaker I'm not sure the United
States has anything about the overseas
development assistance budget uh
recently but I think if you'll indulge
uh Mr Speaker there's a wider point of
news
thank you
um they I think everybody's clear the
secretary of state has said many times
as of I and other ministerial colleagues
that serial under investment in the Army
over decades has led to the point where
the Army is in urgent need of
recapitalization the charts around the
Prime Minister get that and there's a
budget coming
Stephen Hammond five please Mr Speaker
the speaker the national budding
strategy in the National shipbuilding
office is supporting our ambition to
grow the UK shiploading Enterprise and
support UK jobs five new tax credit one
frigates are being built in recite will
support more than a thousand UK jobs the
fleet solar support contract will
deliver 77 million pounds of investment
and create more than 1200 jobs in the UK
shipyards and many more across the UK
supply chain I think it's grouped
Secretary of State
uh
uh Mr Speaker I was I thought it was
drawn or Not Sorry with with permission
could I group it with number eight sorry
that's great can I thank my right
honorable friend for that encouraging
answer he will know that offshore uh
support the vessels will be required for
the crown estate uh offshore wind
licensing leasing Arrangements which is
due to be tendered can he say whether he
could do anything to ensure those
vehicles and sorry those vessels are
made in the UK
ah
first of all obviously those vessels are
predominantly a matter for private
companies or indeed non-government
departments to choose how and why to buy
but of course in order to try and
encourage more UK shipbuilding we
obviously announced last year in the
shipbuilding strategy the home
shipbuilding credit guarantee scheme
which is is there to help in counter the
perverse incentive that it seems to be
that other countries export credits
encourage British companies to build
abroad and obviously been working very
closely with Bayes on this and hopefully
we'll add more details soon
or Blackman speaker and I think my
original friend for his answer thus far
clearly as we replace aging ships and
increase the size of the Navy it's
important that we ensure that those
ships are built in Britain rather than
being built abroad so what measures will
he take to make sure there's a long-term
plan to make sure that our shipbuilders
can plan for the future
find my honorable friend to the National
budding strategy that not only puts
in place lots of measures such as for
example the home shape building
guarantee scheme export credit for
foreign buyers but also a skills plan uh
a yard for the future plan about what a
modern yard should look like although we
can compete with European yards that
already beat us in too many contracts
but also a shipbuilding pipeline
incredibly important to indicate the
industry there is a long-term pipeline
to come through but it is also important
to recognize that if we're going to be
successful like we are in Aerospace
industry will need to export and if we
can export to other markets we have to
recognize the international
collaboration is also part of the
process do I think Australian and Canada
would have bought our type 26s if we've
said nowhere you're only having British
on it the answer would be no and we'd
have all suffered on our supply chain as
a result Toby Perkins thank you very
much Mr Speaker
notwithstanding what the secretary of
state has said there we know that the uh
there are many aspects of the British
shipbuilding industry that does feel
that our government has been less
supportive than some of our competitor
Nations around the way around the world
and if the government continues to award
contracts where large proportions of the
work are completed abroad won't this
undermine uh the British shipbuilding
industry and what the Secretary of State
say something more about how we can
ensure more of these ships are actually
built within UK shipbuilding first
that's a big guy I really urge under not
listen to the propaganda that claptrap
did by the union leadership I went to
Belfast recently I met the local unions
I meant to Appleton at the local unions
you know what they don't agree with
their leadership statements and rather
bizarre propaganda fundamentally the
future solid sportship will be entirely
put together and two-thirds of it nearly
built or supplied through the UK at the
same time as getting 77 million pounds
of investment in The Yards to modernize
the yard in order that our yards compete
for too long our yards have not won
contracts whether from government or
private because we haven't found that
the big Prime contractors invested in
modernizing the skills in the yards and
when I meet the workforce whether it's
in govern or whatever they want to be
invested in we've got to get through all
the questions not just the first one
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I refer
the house to my register of interest uh
speaker as a proud member of NATO
parliamentary assembly I've been lucky
enough to visit some of our NATO
parliamentary um countries like the us
and this and Spain who how you take huge
prize in their buoyance shipbuilding
sector the Secretary of State talks
about the ships being put together in
the country can the minister tell us
with contracts being awarded outside
with large portion would have been
completed how does he expect to keep
investment in the UK I'm sorry it's not
fair to everybody else I'm bringing in
on supplementary it doesn't mean you can
take all that
I can guess the memo that was sent from
the union to The Honorable lady about
what to ask I mean the reality is Mr
Speaker the reality Mr Speaker is what I
can say is unless we invest in our
shipbuilding industry unless we
collaborate internationally we won't
have a ship loading industry we tried it
the other way it didn't work we have to
build collaboratively and you know what
in the Aerospace industry like in Lancia
where we Mr you miss me hi Mr Speaker
are from the typhoon aircraft is of
course an international collaboration
and it's a world beating success
employing tens of thousands of British
people
thank you Mr Speaker in an answer to a
written parliamentary question to me on
the 26th of January 2023 the minister
Minister for defense procurement said
that the type 32 frigates are a key part
of the future Fleet
in the National Audit office report on
the equipment plan the Nao reported that
Navy command withdrew its plans for the
type 32 frigates because of concerns
about unaffordability
how can type 32 frigates be a key part
of the future Fleet if there are
question marks around its affordability
that's because the type 32 frigate when
it comes in wouldn't be till after 2030
or 2031 because it's going to come after
the type 30 ones which are obviously
being constructed as we speak in a
recite uh what what they are going to be
how they're going to be designed and who
built them is obviously a matter between
now and towards the center of the decade
it's also important because even if he
gets into government no treasury will
give you a budget for another seven
years forward to make sure that we don't
sign on the dotted line before we have
the budget in line but it is absolutely
integral Navy to have more frigates and
destroyers including the type 32. number
six sir
so to stay
defense procurement is some of the most
complex in government that our defense
and security industrial strategy
represents a step change that will see
industry government Academia working
closer together while fundamentally
reforming regulations to improve the
speed of acquisition and incentive
Innovation productivity our acquisition
reforms will drive pace and Agility into
procurement to improve delivery
David uh I very much tell the Secretary
of State I very much agree with him on
the need for increased defense
expenditure if we are to remain a tier
one power nevertheless in every one of
the last 25 years the National Audit
office and the Public Accounts committee
have criticized the mod's procurement of
equipment poor identification military
needs poor quality of equipment slow
delivery of projects and inability to
control costs and a corporate culture to
traditional and resistant to change are
just some of the criticisms does he
agree with me that we need to put these
issues right if we are to be a tier one
power
I absolutely agree uh I also you know
first of all it's why I think the second
one nearly third year in a row under my
stewardship the military defense is
going to come in on budget or under
budget for the first time in decades to
make sure that we live within our means
but secondly I think it's also important
to point out and it is always a
challenge for any sector-safe to vent
that treasuries like to deal in one two
three or four years some of the programs
we're talking about the type 31 one for
example earlier Futures all the support
are decades long and in that long
process of complexity threat changes
technology changes inflation changes and
indeed all the challenges are around and
that's important whether we're going to
have governments invest in long-term
infrastructure whether it's civil or
military to understand that long-term
Investments is a different risk profile
and if we do everything year by year
we'll always end up in a similar
position
the state will be aware that there are
growing concerns about the impact of
delays and the management of Defense
programs on our defense Readiness so
what specifically is he doing to ensure
that the UK will meet our UK NATO
obligations in full good question well
we're still on track and maintain above
two percent of GDP if that's the
obligation The Honorable lady is
referring to off defense spending and
we're still on trajectory to do that it
is of course important as my honorable
colleagues and point out across the
house to make sure we get good value for
money and it's also important we try and
deliver on time some programs are on
time 85 percent of Defense programs do
actually come on time the major
collaborative ones or the major complex
ones over long long terms are often the
ones that causes problems we do need to
improve that we need to make sure we
don't overspect Mr Speaker we need to
make sure that also where possible we
collaborate and indeed improve internal
mechanisms that often hold up things
because the UK has some of the highest
defense procurement standards in the
world and I'm glad the government is
seeking to drive over the standards
still further under my original friends
at leadership
in cooperating with our International
friends and allies and partners in
particular Ukraine does the defense
secretary agree with me it's absolutely
vital that those Partners have similar
levels of the transparency in their
defense procurement in order to keep
public confidence for support for
Ukraine yeah it it it's very important
that not only is actually across the
International Community that the
donations we're all making the public
get a sense of where they're going and
how they're being used and it was
important on a recent visit I met with
ukrainians indeed other International
Partners to make sure we put in place
some form of assurance so that what
we're sending we know where it is going
because they think soon our public will
quite rightly say what's happening to it
but it's also important that we
recognize what Ukraine has showed us is
that Supply chains whether they're
domestic or multinational have to be
supported in order to make sure that at
times of need we're able to Surge them
rather than blowing the dust off and
taking months or years to reopen
thank you Mr Speaker the secretary of
state has indicated Ukraine was made
graphically clear that long-term
ordering is absolutely vital to the
defense industry and to maintain
capacity both um both machinery and also
also Manpower so does he accept that the
failure need to place orders for new
submarines nuclear submarines between
2010 and 2016 even though there was a
clear majority for that in this house
was a major strategic error yeah
I'm very grateful tonight because if he
I do deal with him I often do it to try
and do a deal with my right honorable
gentleman opposite if he admits too that
there were not the only example of that
we have all made strategic errors in our
defense policies over the last two
decades because we've had treasuries
that have done short term we have
hollowed out as company governments of
the government have wanted more but not
wanted to fund it his government was no
different I was serving in the Army
under his government I know exactly what
it was like
so the Ajax program has been so
controversial that the Secretary of
State personally commissioned an
independent review by Clive Sheldon QC
into the flow of information surrounding
it has the secretary of state yet
received Mr Sheldon's report when does
he intend to publish it and can he
promise the house he will do so in full
and unredacted
informed by my uh right on my friend the
minister development that is coming
imminently and imminently I hope that
means a few weeks not a month I will
read it and then of course I will make
sure certainly at the very least the
findings I shared with the house but I'm
very happy to have a discussion with
defense select committee about how much
we can share with it subject to uh if
there are any security concerns the good
news is uh the Ajax is now starting its
next phase of its trials as I've always
said to this house I am determined to
fix this troubled program we asked we
are now on the way to getting through
its next most important trials having
passed its user viability trials up
until Christmas so I'm going to try and
fix that program get it delivered at the
same time I'm delighted to learn the
lessons I'm Jarvis Mr Speaker the mod
procure services to administer Defense
Housing and accommodation it's now over
a month since my urgent question when
the minister said Vivo Amy and Pinnacle
are are I know in no doubt about The
Minister's profound disadvant
distraction at their performance but
since then there have been more cases of
poor repair and poor service so can the
ministers the Secretary of State say
specifically with regard to defense
accommodation is the procurement process
fit for purpose and does he have
confidence in the current providers yeah
yeah well it's a timely question by The
Honorable gentleman uh this weekend I
looked at the different options about uh
whether we can find either compensation
or recompense from the providers in the
first place and I get a weekly update on
each individual cases how many cases are
in the queues in some areas they have
made progress in some areas their
progress is comparable or better than
the private sector there is still work
to be done on it I'm most concerned
about mold and dampness uh being opening
in areas around heating we have seen
some success but we do expect a better
service my honorable friend the minister
defense procurement is regularly meeting
with them but it is also important to
note that uh you know we will we will
keep even their contracts under review
and if if we don't get a better standard
then there are other steps I will take
yeah thank you Mr Speaker
um the question from my colleague from
Barnsley Central is a good one because
the government's failure on defense
procurement isn't limited just the
weapons and ammunition you only need to
speak to those people in Defense Housing
with leaky roofs black mold and broken
boilers to realize that defense
procurement is failing the people who
serve our military and their families
the mod last year paid 144 million to
private contractors to maintain these
service families accommodations yet many
of these homes are still waiting repairs
not getting the service that they
deserve so as the as one of his
ministers has admitted these contracts
do not represent value for taxpayers
money why did the mod sign these
contracts in the first place and when
will he be able to tell all our troops
that they have a home fit for Heroes
yeah yeah but we always want our homes
to be fit for the men and women of our
armed forces and uh I distinctly
remember my time in Germany and indeed
in the UK living under a standard of
home when it was done in-house and I can
assure you there were issues then if not
in some cases worse what we have been
monitoring however is making sure we get
these reports answered uh it was
interesting that the the start point of
some of these problems was the lack of
Manning of the very beginning the
helpline when people were ringing up at
Christmas there's almost no one there
and then working through this whole
process look we are trying to do more
about it we will hold them to account we
will take Financial action against them
or whatever if we have to and I'm I'm
not shy about doing it we will try and
seek compensation for those people
suffering and improve what's happening
but we are also seeing in some areas
that wait over five days are getting
better and that's the first point and
then we're getting closer
thank you Mr Speaker
um multiple major procurement projects
for which the submarine delivery agency
is responsible for are late over budget
are often both taxpayers are used to the
concept of bonuses but in the real world
these bonuses are linked to Performance
and those same taxpayers are
hemorrhaging billions of the hardened
taxes on the demonstrable failures of
the mod not the least of which is within
the SDA so how can the Secretary of
State justify six-figure bonuses to
Executives of failing mod agencies and
on the eminently reasonable supposition
that he can't defend the undefensible
what will he do to rectify those
incoherent remuneration packages going
forward
what what the payments represent is that
we have made a number of new
appointments and are turning around the
submit development agency to improve the
availability at one of the areas of deep
concern has been the consequences of
hollowing out over the decades has been
about the maintenance the availability
of dry docks and others and things like
devonport that allow us to turn
submarines round to make sure they are
maintained in time to get them to better
availability it's important it is going
well it is important Mr Speaker to
sometimes change the workforce and make
sure you get the best capable people you
can to change around I'm confident the
new team is able to do that and I'm
looking forward to seeing the results
question seven Mr Speaker
[Applause]
with permission Mr Speaker I'll answer
numbers 7 and 17 together Mr Speaker on
Thursday I had the very great pleasure
of visiting Lancashire in particular
veterans UK at Norcross where I met some
really great people providing a range of
support to our veterans one of the
biggest impediments to progress is
around data consequently we are putting
40 million into a transformation program
which will digitize our existing
processes enabling our staff to provide
more effective and efficient support to
our personal veterans and substantially
improving their experience
Robin Miller
Mr Speaker our veterans and their
families have made an invaluable
contribution to securing our freedoms
and our nation but broadly only about a
quarter of them are in receipt of a
pension which entitles them to support
from the veterans advisory pensions
committees across the UK will the
minister join me first in paying
tributes to the work of the apcs and
supporting veterans and secondly will he
support my private members bill on
February the 24th which seeks to extend
their remit and expand the cohort of
veterans to whom they can offer
assistance
I'm very grateful to my honorable friend
vapcs provide a wonderful and unsung
Service as did the war pension
committees before them and of course I
look forward to the 24th of February and
will give his bill my whole hearted
support
Murray River
Mr Speaker those prepared to make the
ultimate sacrifice to keep our country
safe should not have to rely on benefits
to get by how does the minister plan on
helping veterans reliant on Universal
Credit acquire the skills they need to
access well-paid and promised
very grateful to The Honorable lady
she'll be aware of the career transition
part partnership she will be aware too
of the special Arrangements that exist
for those veterans who are unfortunately
ill or injured to get them into civilian
life in a seamless way and provide them
with the skills that they need for the
rest of their lives important to
understand that all servicemen and all
service women are civilians in waiting
they all return to the communities from
which they're drawn and throughout their
careers they will have preparation to
enable them to do so in a seamless
fashion as possible with the skills that
they need James Sunderland
Mr speaker thank you the minister will
know that the veterans or party group
are currently running a survey into the
experience of veterans across the UK
when claiming compensation War pensions
or the fiscal support veterans UK that
survey closes tomorrow so will you
please agree to meet me to discuss the
findings of that survey and depending on
what they say does he agree in principle
to any measures which better assure the
outputs of veterans UK
well I'm very grateful to my honorable
and Grant friend for his chairmanship of
the veterans all party parliamentary
group and for the survey that he has
undertaken I am very much looking
forward to the results of that survey
he'll be aware that mod of course itself
does a variety of surveys and canvassing
to ensure that we are giving our serving
Personnel our veterans and their
families what they need to pursue their
careers and their lived experience it is
positive but I'm very much looking
forward to what his group has to say and
of course I'll meet with him I'm doing
Gwen thank you the minister will know
and appreciate that mental ill health
affects disproportionately uh veterans
and their families the cost of living
crisis is putting even more pressure on
uh access to Mental Health Services
according to Veterans Charities the
labor party has committed to a 35
million pound investment in veterans
mental health I asked this sincerely of
the minister will he match that yeah
well firstly I have to correct The
Honorable gentleman he's not right to
say that veterans or indeed defense
Personnel are more likely than the
general public to suffer from mental
health problems the reverse is the case
however it is absolutely essential we do
all in our power to promote the mental
health of our men and women absolutely
right and he will be aware of a number
of projects including op courage and
throughout people's careers in which
their mental health is promoted and we
will continue to do that but he does
need to understand that defense is a
positive experience of the vast majority
of people who experience it
Shadow Minister Rachel Hopkins yeah yeah
thank you Mr Speaker the initial
headline findings of the independent
review of the Armed Forces compensation
scheme state that the process is overly
burdensome and even distressing for the
claimant due to unreasonable time frames
and a lack of transparency this is but
one of a number of concerns raised about
the compensation scheme all of which
veterans across the country have been
telling us about for a very long time
veterans who've made huge sacrifices to
keep our country safe deserve far better
from this government so can the minister
tell the house when the full report will
be published and what he's doing to
ensure its findings will be acted upon
swiftly
well The Honorable ladies referring to
the queen cranial review which has
published its interim findings and will
publish its definitive report in the
spring she's right to highlight some of
the findings of that of that report in
its interim form and of course we'll
take into account all of those well I'm
if the honorable lady will allow me in
the spring when the report is is
published one of those things Mr Speaker
is to ensure that the system is less
adversarial than it previously has been
but we have to understand a lot of the
delay is baked in because of the need to
obtain a proper full comprehensive
medical reports so I believe
thank you Mr Speaker the type 32 program
began the concept phase on the 21st of
September 2022 and will seek to deliver
an outline business case in Spring 2024.
the program and procurement strategy
will be decided following the concept
phase in the normal way but further to
the exchange between the Secretary of
State and the shadow Minister earlier
this afternoon
uh can the minister confirmed that
whilst I understand that this type 32
so-called won't come on stream until
2030. the government is fully committed
to having an ongoing warship program
doesn't matter whether we call it the 31
a or 32 or whatever we we remain
committed to renewing the Royal Navy's
capability after 2030.
thank you Mr Speaker yes and last week I
had the pleasure of being in recite
where we were cutting steel or steel was
being cut in respect of type 31 and that
is an affordable frigate which is able
to be configured for the mission so
whether that's a humanitarian Mission or
War fighting Mission uh or anti-piracy
Mission that is exactly what we want our
frigates to be flexible and we want them
to ensure that there's a pipeline into
the future
Mr Speaker the UK our allies and
partners are responding decisively to
provide military and humanitarian
assistance to Ukraine the UK has led the
world with the gifting of modern main
battle tanks to Ukraine and our engaging
International Partners through a
coordinated military and diplomatic
effort Secretary of State for defense
Martin will friend should take some
personal credit for this as they've
returned throughout the last year has
been him that has sought to understand
what the ukrainians need next and has
rallied support across Europe and Beyond
in that gifting Aaron Bell can I thank
my honorable friend for his answer can I
concur with him that we have shown the
way on Ukraine we've consistently been
at the Forefront and he mentioned battle
tanks and it was our announcement that
set the precedent that let our allies
make their announcements last week in
the same vein can my honorable friend
confirm that we will continue to lead
the way on support for Ukraine by
pushing our allies to match our
commitment that we will send as much
military aid to Ukraine this year or
more than we did last year
well Mr Speaker the government has
already committed the same amount of
money for this year as it did for lastly
in that sense the job is already done
but of course how the money this year is
used will depend very much on this on
what's going on on the ground and that's
the most important part of this gifting
program the relationship between the UK
and Ukraine is now so strong that we're
able to discuss very candidly each
other's plans and to make sure that
we're supporting them every step of the
way
today Mr Speaker well we heard before
Christmas that the government had
finally signed a contract to replenish
in-laws but in order to ensure that we
can continue to be a leader in the
international effort in Ukraine how many
other contracts have been signed to
replace the consumable military age
which has been sent to Ukraine
Mr Speaker High Velocity missiles have
already been placed on contract and
other systems that have been donated
many of them already in the process of
being updated and they were gifted
coming to the end of their life within
our current inventory and thus they
wouldn't be expected to be placed on
contract because they're part of a
routine procurement process
SMP Sports person Dave do
Mr Speaker much of the international
support going to Ukraine will be
deployed to defend ukrainians against
the barbarity of the private militia the
Wagner group so can the minister explain
to the UK's allies why the UK government
made available frozen assets of Wagner's
leader yevgeni pregajin in order that
you could take a case out against the
British
um a journalist and given this
inexplicable accommodation can the
minister confirm does this Tory
government roll out the red carpet
exclusively for Russian Warlords or is
this an inclusive UK service available
to war criminals everywhere
Mr Speaker
the presence of Wagner on the front line
in the donbass is clearly a reflection
of just how bad things have got for
Putin and the Russian armed forces that
a mercenary group recruiting from
prisons is required as to the
substantive pathology missed questions
sounds like it might be a question for
my treasury colleagues and I'll make
sure that they write him with an answer
Frank Smith number 12 Lisa
with permission Mr Speaker I should like
to answer number 12 together with 18 and
20. the ministry of Defense Works
closely with British industry and
Academia including smes to identify and
invest in Innovative Technologies that
address our most pressing capability
challenges as well as publishing our
future priorities to incentivize
investment we are already testing and
deploying those Technologies
thank you Mr Speaker the best Innovation
isn't necessarily The Preserve of the
giant players in the sector but smaller
Enterprises such as those found at the
Westcott Venture Park in my constituency
like flair Bright's development of
autonomous drones for flight in gnss
denied areas so can my honorable friend
assure me that these smaller Dynamic
Enterprises are as valued to his
department when it comes to developing
new defense Innovations as the more
traditional big beasts well my honorable
friend is absolutely right a lot of the
Innovation does indeed come from those
agile smes and that's why the mod's SME
action plan is very firmly aimed at
improving access for smes to work right
through the defense supply chain the mod
indeed has a Target that 25 of its
procurement spend will go directly and
indirectly to smes which is up from
around 16 in 2016 latest figures I've
seen were at 23 already we're on the
right path further to go
the Tempest fighter jet and the
challenge 103 tank are examples of this
government's commitment to giving our
forces a good quality Equipment but does
my honorable friend agree that we must
also prioritize the well-being of our
personnel and one of the ways we can do
this is to ensure that the quality of
food matches the caliber of their kit
very grateful to my honorable friend he
is of course absolutely right ensuring
that our service Personnel received good
quality meals is a virtual contribution
to defense capability and that's why the
defense has estab Ministry defenses
established a team of subject matter
experts to overhaul and modernize
defense catering delivery using the
findings of the delivering defense
dining quality review and the ongoing
Army eats trials to inform change to the
total food offer the trials began in
2020 the results are expected imminently
and that will inform the future of
dining for defense well come on Stephen
thank you Mr Speaker if we want to keep
our country safe we need to work with
our allies to make sure that we remain
at the Forefront of the latest
developments in defense technology can I
write a little friend therefore confirm
that our partnership with Japan our new
partnership with Japan and Italy will
involve collaborating on areas such as
weapons and uavs and not just on fighter
jets
to my honorable gentleman so the
ambition of This truly international
program is principally to deliver a
cutting-edge fighter aircraft providing
a credible deterrent to Future threats
he knows this is a system of systems and
it's likely to include uncrewed aircraft
new sensors weapons Advanced Data
Systems and secure networks and those
wider capabilities may be developed
together with wider Partners or indeed
together with our existing Partners in
that endeavor we will continue to
explore system opportunities both
between our core partnership and more
widely
thank you Mr Speaker following the
recent memorandum of understanding
signed by the RAF and Imperial College
London how do ministers expect this will
impact the raf's technological
capabilities particularly around digital
and artificial intelligence
well of course digital artificial
intelligence are absolutely Central to
our capability I was delighted to
announce recently significant investment
that has taken place in Lincolnshire to
ensure that when those aircraft take to
the skies they have all the um weapon
system but also the battlefield
management plans that they require to
ensure that they can take the fight to
the enemy Ford number 13 Please Mr
Speaker
Mr Speaker the National Security Bill
contains Provisions that will help in
Prosecuting those who use their
knowledge and expertise to train foreign
militaries produce or to the interests
of the UK in the meantime while the bill
passes through this house and the other
has we've issued guidance to all defense
Personnel at risk and reminded person of
the obligation to protect centers of
information this has led to improved
reporting of suspicious activity which
report
I uh thank the Secretary of State for
that helpful response qualified RAF
Pilots are quitting for better paid jobs
that involve training other countries
Air Forces and fixed-wing aircraft have
dropped by nearly a quarter since 2017.
we learned last week that all of the
raf's hawk jet trainer aircraft have
been grounded because of an engine issue
given that the government will be in the
high court tomorrow in an effort to
justify supplying arms for use in the
war in Yemen what does he have to say to
MPS across the house who are concerned
about the deployment of RAF Personnel to
Saudi Arabia in the last couple of
months to train the Royal Saudi Air
Force
I have absolutely no problem with
supporting our friend and Ally in the
region Saudi Arabia we've done it for
decades and we'll continue to do so
we come to topicals Miracle before
number one Mr Speaker named
Mr Speaker colleagues may have read
reports this weekend about activity
conducted by the Army's counter
disinformation unit in 17 Brigade online
disinformation from foreign State actors
is a serious threat to the United
Kingdom which is why during the pandemic
we brought together expertise from acts
across government to monitor this
information about covid 77 Brigade is a
hybrid unit of regular Reserve Personnel
that has established in 2015 it delivers
information activities as part of
broader military effects against hostile
State actors and violent extremist
organizations based outside the UK it
uses publicly available data including
materials shared on social media
platforms to assess UK disinformation
Trends it is not to be involved in
regulating policing or even reporting
opinion that it may or may not agree
with
thank you Mr Speaker my constituent
Daniel was medically discharged from the
Army in 2015. yet in September 2022
Daniel was only awarded tariff 10
compensation is housebound and fully
reliant on his mother and psychiatrist's
degree that his condition is sadly
permanent seven years on and Daniel is
still without the compensation that
reflects the severity of his of his
mental injury so will the minister meet
with me to review this case an ensure
that veterans who suffer psychological
injuries are equally compensated with
those who suffer physical injuries I'll
be delighted to meet with the honorable
lady discuss the case Robert courts you
are Mr Speaker I've been to see some of
the RF housing in costan recently and
with molding homes with children present
or repairs that have been requested but
not completed it seems that the Pinnacle
Vivo partnership is failing military
families water ministers doing to hold
them to account well I'm very very
grateful to my little friend for raising
this I know Fry's quite well I know the
accommodation that he's referring to he
may be aware that all tlbs are meant to
be assessing now or their accommodation
against the Defense Housing standard and
will report by the end of the year in
the meantime he should know that 10
billion over the uh correction 1.6
billion over the next 10 years will be
invested in Barracks accommodation to
improve some of the uh truly awful
accommodation at Saudi our men and women
have to put up with show Secretary of
State John peely thank you Mr Speaker
this month the government made important
but again ad hoc announcements for more
military help for Ukraine we're still
waiting for the 2023 action plan of
support for Ukraine first promised by
the defense secretary last August will
he publish this ahead of the first
anniversary of Russia's invasion next
month
I do totally agree the right honorable
gentleman that we need to set out a plan
but can I also tell him and I've I've
chased it in advance of these questions
from the previous our donations are not
ad hoc right there there is a there's a
view abroad that somehow these are just
ad hoc and the ukrainians pick up the
telephone fundamentally the donations
are set by what happens on the ground by
the reaction to the Russian to Ukrainian
defense and how Ukraine needs to adapt
it's not an ad hoc thing it's a very
deliberate process mainly quoted by the
United Kingdom and her allies and
therefore this is it's really important
to separate that from an overall
strategy about announcing to Parliament
the different lines of effort that we
take to counter Russia
thank you Mr Speaker last week the
defense secretary said the Armed Forces
had faced what he called a consistent
hollowing out under labor and early
conservative governments but when labor
left government in 2010 Mr Speaker the
British army stood at over a hundred
thousand full-time troops and we were
spending 2.5 percent of uh GDP on
defense the serious hollowing out has
happened since who does he think's been
in charge over the last 13 years
you only have to Mr Speaker listen to
the veterans on this side to understand
their experience under a labor
government snatch snatch Land Rovers
let's remember that and and all that
awful mess as a result of of the labor
government's investment the the deal
here is quite simple if the ride on a
gentleman opposite wants to wants to be
the next section of Defense he should
come here and get off his chest the
shortcomings that his former government
did I'm happy to say that we have
hollowed out and underfunded will he do
the same or will he hide behind Petty
Party politics
[Applause]
last week I visited his Majesty's Naval
Base Clyde with the Armed Forces
parliamentary scheme and want to pay
tribute to the absolutely remarkable men
and women we met there who make up our
nation's submarine service given that we
live in ever more dangerous times can my
ride on my friend confirm to the house
that this conservative government
remains absolutely committed to delivery
of the new dread Court a Dreadnought
class of submarines to be based in
Scotland to provide a continuous at Sea
deterrence and so protect our United
Kingdom for decades yeah yeah
so I'm glad that the uh my honorable
friend and many other colleagues went to
Fast Lane last week and that they
enjoyed their visit we are of course
committed to the replacement of Vanguard
submarines with Dreadnought but more
importantly he mentions the brilliant
people based at fazlene Who deliver day
in day out our nation's nuclear
deterrent unseen under the oceans of the
world they are incredible people doing
amazing work
sorry
non-uk veterans who settle here after
their service do not pay Visa fees but
it is surely not right that this doesn't
extend to their dependence will the man
will the minister match our commitment
on these benches to change that
well I'm very grateful to The Honorable
German I can't give them the undertaking
that he asked for me or understand that
obviously all things are kept under
review but we do value the service of
those from overseas who serve in his
Majesty's Armed Forces clearly and I
think most of them have a very positive
experience
they'll come back huh very much we ought
to be extremely proud of the
government's impact of we are the second
largest supplier of military equipment
to the ukrainians in the entire world
only second the United States America
today we have our troops training the
Ukrainian troops on how to use the
Challenger 2 tanks can I ask the
minister when that those will be
deployed onto the battlefield so we can
start to see a serious impact in
bringing this heinous War to an end
well obviously if security reasons
Marvel fund I can't I can't term Animal
Friend exactly the timings what I can
say is it starts with training on the
individual operation the platforms then
on training on being able to uh join
together with formation units to fight
as a formed unit because that's
important and then from then those tanks
will be put in uh what I can say it'll
be this side of the summer or may it'll
be probably towards Easter Thailand
Michael thank you Mr Speaker 45
of Cheshire military personnel are
living in the lowest standard of single
accommodation that's 220. that's pretty
shameful and something needs to happen
about it quite urgently how does the
minister ensure that they have homes
genuinely fit for Heroes well I'm very
grateful to The Honorable gentleman 97
of mod service family accommodation
meets or exceeds the government housing
standard however at that speed of the
most local authorities and better than
most registered social landlords so he
may be interested to know because I
looked it up earlier that 105 homes in
his labor-controlled local Authority uh
that are owned by that local Authority
are below the decent house home
standards and I suggest he takes it up
with his Council
[Music]
okay Mr Speaker I'm sure the minister
will join me in thanking the wonderful
team at the defense National
Rehabilitation Center which is based in
rushcliffe the amazing work they do
treating injured members of our armed
forces can I ask the minister what
assessment he's made of how the
expertise and the cutting-edge
technology at that Center could be
shared with our Ukrainian allies and to
help rehabilitate Ukrainian Heroes who
are injured on the front line the
question I'm very grateful to my
honorable friend as it happens last
Monday I visited the defense medical
Rehabilitation Center I also heard about
the nhs-led National Rehabilitation
Center that hopefully will be stood up
by the end of next year and together
they will be able to provide a truly
trailblazing International Center for
rehabilitation and for research
obviously this country stands by to help
Ukraine in their fight against Putin in
any way possible including in the
rehabilitation of its brave men who have
given so much not only in the defense of
Ukraine but also in defense of the rest
of us Mr Speaker Labor's dossier of the
West in the mod found that at least 15
billion has been wasted in taxpayers
money since 2010. can the minister
explain why the government is failing to
get a grip of the defense procurement
process to secure value for money for
the taxpayer
called dossier as far as dodgy wants to
go because half the waste was under
labor government in it
Dr Julian Lewis
speaker will the Secretary of State join
with me in applauding Poland's historic
announcement today that it's raising its
defense budget to four percent of GDP
and can he imagine what conclusion I
think our government ought to draw from
that example
my right honor friend always tends to be
I I think I I think uh the polls who are
on the front line and have shown
tremendous leadership uh in the face of
Russia's growing aggression not only to
itself but also to its neighbors and
friends in in Ukraine I think the
conclusion they have drawn is the world
is a dangerous unstable place and it's
not likely to get less so anytime soon
and carbon
thank you Mr Speaker the call for
evidence for the LGBT veterans
independent review revealed that the
police records of veterans convicted
during the ban on homosexuality were
destroyed now in answers to
parliamentary questions the department
says this was in line with uh data
protection but in letters to Veterans it
says this decision was taken by defense
police Chiefs Council who directed that
all investigations into offenses
relating solely to sexuality were to be
removed from our systems and deleted
from the records can can the Secretary
of State or ministers write to me to
clarify this and will they consider
making the council meetings with the
defense police Chiefs public
The Honorable gentleman for raising this
between 1967 and 2000 there's no
question that people of the LGBT
community were badly dealt with by
defense and that's why we've set up the
Etherton review which will report
shortly and I can tell you having met
with Lord Atherton that he will be
forensic in his examination of the data
I think I can assure The Honorable
gentleman however that the handling of
records as far as we can tell was in
accordance with civilian practice but of
course we stand by and wait for his
lordship to a pine on the matter and
we'll comment further when he has done
so
thank you Mr Speaker uh can I write on a
friend set out what preparations his
departments have made in terms of the
support for overseas territories in the
Caribbean during this year's hurricane
season
well Mr Speaker I enjoyed working my
right humble friend when she was the
minister for the overseas territories
and she's right to care about this she
will know that the department has done a
lot of work over the last few years to
develop the resilience of the overseas
territories as well as maintaining Naval
Assets in the region and more at
Readiness to assist if required maybe a
permanent business and the old cheese
will tell Judith Cummins thank you Mr
Speaker during my recent visit to
Ukraine with the right honorable member
for chingford and Woodford green
Ukrainian officials were very clear
about their need for increased Military
Support with the United States
reportedly discussing the creation of a
fighter jet Coalition with Ukraine and
the German Chancellor currently ruling
out sending fighter jets to Ukraine what
assessment is a government made
regarding building such a coalition with
our motor allies well
having taken the battle on getting tanks
into Ukraine obviously uh understandably
people then ask about what next
capability I think what we know about
all these demands is that eventually uh
the initial response is no and they end
up being yes so we will see we will
track the progress but as I say it is
not based on ad hoc it's based on need
and defined what's needed in the
battlefield of course we will keep our
minds open all the time about what is
possible to do next then Carolina
speaker I warmly welcome the
announcement of 1.6 billion pounds to
repair and refurbish on-site based
accommodation as the minister rightly
says the accommodation in both HMS
Sultan and HMS Collingwood is truly
awful meanwhile uh we hear that in the
Portsmouth area alone the Royal Navy are
spending millions of pounds a year
putting people up in hotels while fought
Blockhouse within my gospel constituency
which he knows very well remains empty
when are the Emoji going to address this
I'm very grateful to my right honorable
friend I know she knows the fort
Blockhouse intimately as indeed do I
it's aesthetically Charming but it is
beyond reasonable repair in terms of
accommodating servicemen and service
women are concerned we're spending money
on HMS Collingwood I hope it be brought
up to spec shortly Rachel Basco thank
you Mr Speaker my Constitution
Al a week today will be made homeless
from a hostel by city of York Council
who's a signature to the Armed Forces
Covenant what states can he make to
ensure that she and her three children
are not homeless a week today
uh well I'm grateful to them honorable
lady obviously I can't comment on on
these specific the details which I don't
have she sends to me I will certainly
look into them but every local Authority
that signed up to the Armed Forces
Covenant needs to be mindful of its duty
to look after servicemen service women
and their families
the charity solution
presented to them having suffered a
sexual assault they presented at defense
Community Mental Health Services but
subsequently discharged from the
military due to having a personality
disorder I wrote to the minister for
further information none was available
so would the minister look into the
service to make sure that due clinical
rigor is applied before people are
discharged with a personality disorder
well I'm grateful to my honorable friend
and predecessor I've seen no evidence
that people are being misdiagnosed or
mismanaged the matter of course is is
for healthcare Professionals in
particular consultant psychiatrists I
can't really interfere with their
diagnoses I've noted her concerns and I
will certainly look into the matter
very Sherman Mr Speaker would the
Secretary of State agree with me that
what we've learned from Ukraine surely
is the future of good defense is going
to be in having the latest technology
and Innovation are there any new schemes
that we could we could have that
increase the investment in that new
technology and especially partnership
with other countries across NATO
uh he's absolutely first of all the
Diana uh thing uh a unit within NATO I'm
delighted we jointly share the European
headquarters with Estonia because I
thought it was important to partner with
a small Innovative company country to
make sure we get the very best between
us that's one of them our r d budget 6.6
billion pounds one of the leaders in
government in investing it but of course
the real lesson which has always been a
problem is not only is it important to
invest in the inventions it's pulling it
through International requirement that's
traditionally where the defense has
fallen down and determined to fix that
and that means focusing our r d where we
know there's a need by our armed
services
thank you Mr Speaker many veterans in
East Evan tell me they sometimes
struggle to adapt from Frontline service
into jobs available locally it is a huge
change the scars of service can be
challenging can my right normal friend
provide an update on the work of the
defense transition service which
supports veterans into good well-paid
jobs grateful to my honorable friend he
might be referring to the career
transition partnership which is the
partnership that is normally used for
people transitioning into civilian life
the DTs is for those who have in some
way been injured or have sustained an
illness that is designed to make sure
that people have the support they need
to adapt to their particular
circumstance ensure they have the best
chance possible of getting a decent
civilian job after they leave the
services and it's very successful in so
doing it as is the CTP Earth thank you
Mr Speaker recent news report detailing
14 and a half thousand urgent
maintenance appointments at Armed Forces
homes being missed are very concerning
so would my right honorable friend
reassure me and my constituents in South
and West he's taking every step to
ensure all our soldiers can live in good
quality homes
well absolutely it's the top priority
certainly for me I know for the
Secretary of State and for Min DP what
we have to bear in mind is 97 of those
houses are above at the government
housing standards so they are better
than most councils and better than most
registered social landlords but we must
do better than we are at the moment and
we're we're bending ourselves to that
task let's learn Saxby speaker can my
right honorable friend confirm that UK
operational sovereignty will be a factor
in the increment 1A of the maritime
electronic warfare program and mighty
meet with me to discuss
I'm very grateful honorable lady for
that the important question I will write
yes Secretary of State at the
to the allegations in the Press at the
weekend relating to the 77 Brigade now I
know him well enough that when he tells
us that the he gave clear instructions
and guidelines to Brigade to only
operate against foreign powers and
extremists he was telling the exact
truth will he however review the issue
and ensure that his guidelines have been
followed in all cases yeah yeah at my
right on my friend uh thank you for the
compliment yes I have and I've already
instructed that we look into not only
the story but indeed my instructions
that I personally issued after a visit
were carried out that completes
questions we now come to the oral State
I'll just let that route
the chamber player
thank you
all right we now come to understand it
urgent and Emergency Care recovery plan
I call the Secretary of State for health
Mr Speaker today we are publishing our
new delivery plan for recovering urgent
and emergency care services which has
been deposited in the libraries of both
houses
scale of the pandemic pressures which
Healthcare Systems around the world and
indeed across the UK are collectively
facing we are building the NHS back to
where we want it to be
this requires the widespread adoption of
innovation building on best practice
already being applied in specific trusts
together with significant investment in
these new ways of working including a
14.1 billion funding boost to Health and
Social care as set out in the Autumn
statement
today's announcement is the second of
three plans to cut waiting times